more now on the impeachment inquiry we
can bring in Melanie Sloan she's a
former federal prosecutor and partner at
the crisis management firm summer
strategy she's joining us from
Washington DC thanks very much for
speaking to us so how significant is it
that Mike Pompeo was not only on the
call but is now accused of trying to
prevent people from the State
Department's from testifying and we
heard Adams chef speaking about this
just a short while ago at that press
conference well it's not just that
secretary Pompeo is accused of that of
trying to prevent people from talking to
the Senate at the House Intelligence
Committee he's he specifically stated
that Pompeo has said himself that people
can't go and and several people are
going anyway for one kurt volker the
former envoy has already agreed that he
is in fact going to going to have going
to testify the former ukrainian
ambassador is going to testify next week
and it is completely reasonable that
House Intelligence chair Adam Schiff
said that he would draw the committee
would draw a negative inference that mr.
Pompeo was attempting to obstruct
justice by preventing people from coming
forward I think the real question is
also what did the secretary the
inspector general over at the State
Department say this morning apparently
there was a meeting between the House
Intelligence Committee and the IG and he
he had asked for an urgent meeting to
discuss documents that he wanted to
share from the State Department so I'm
sure we'll be learning more about that
in the coming days but it's clearly
ramping the investigation is ramping up
they're moving full steam ahead it was
also interesting that mr. Schiff noted
that he and Elijah Cummings Elijah
Cummings who's the chair of the House
Oversight Committee we're going to be
issuing subpoenas to the White House in
addition that's going to undoubtedly
result in a full-fledged battle we won't
be surprised at all to see this wind up
in the courts
yeah we've really got a sense from Adam
Schiff on how quickly you may say the
Democrats are moving ahead with this
investigation when he said we're
proceeding deliberately and we feel a
sense of urgency but at the same time
when you look at President Trump's
tweets for example what he's saying as
well as some of the pub
Hawkins is that they're likening this to
a coup what's your reaction to that well
obviously that's ridiculous the United
States Constitution imagines the concept
of impeachment it's right there in the
four corners of the document so that's
not a coup for the for the house to go
forward with its constitutional
authority to investigate the president
and consider impeachment at the same
time this is a White House that has
shown that it's willing to amp up its
mature sponsz at any moment and try to
rally supporters with extreme language
that's not at all unusual and we also
know that the president is not all that
interested in complying they were very
recalcitrant in responding to the Muller
investigation mr. Muller never required
mr. Trump to testify personally and back
down from the fight with the White House
and I don't think Adam Schiff however is
going to back down in the same way so
when they issue subpoenas to the White
House and the White House refuses to
comply I think we'll find the matter in
the federal courts and it will be very
interesting to see how that goes
particularly in light of in another case
yesterday a federal judge a
well-respected Republican appointed
federal judge talked about how this is a
dark time and he is concerned about
obstruction at the White House are you
getting a sense at all how much public
appetite there is for this impeachment
inquiry going forward well new polls
issued today show that the public is
increasingly supportive of impeachment
so while Trump's base still is with him
and the president has raised record
amounts of campaign cash more and more
public is concerned and as we see the
State Department the Secretary of State
refusing to comply with subpoena and we
can also expect to see subpoenas issued
to bill bar over at the Department of
Justice given that he has been traveling
the world attempting to gain information
to combat mr. Trump's to support mr.
Trump's view of the mulher investigation
we could expect to see subpoenas there I
mean there's now a new report that mr.
Trump
was attempting to ask Boris Johnson over
in England in the UK to also help him go
against the Muller investigation and the
Russia probe so there's more and more of
this contact with foreign leaders for
potentially improper purposes and I
think we're going to be learning so much
more about all of this in the coming
days all right Melanie stone thank you
for speaking to us from Washington